oh yeah how many people
watching right now are gonna be in dubai
or maybe are from dubai
because yeah i'll be i'll be in dubai
for three weeks
during the match
i feel bad this person
has been waiting their whole life
or maybe the whole summer
to play me and now is just
maybe not conscious
okay all abort
summers baker if you challenge me again
i'll look for you in the list and give
you a game
okay new random sub
playing evanism
also never played before
i feel like evanism is a multi-time
resub
white moves first
provisional rating ooh
[Music]
okay
what to play
let's play an ortho schnapp
feels like it's been ages since my last
ortho shop
yeah i'll take and play
oh this is rated rapid
uh that's okay
ah the leeches command is maybe broken
which means
i might have to fix it
but first i have to take free pawns
oh no my sleep
oh no my salad
i feel like salads probably taste better
if they're well rested
thank you paradox salad
i hope you can get some sleep eventually
wait do plants
do plants ever sleep
or is that just not a thing that plants
do
i mean salads probably
maybe it depends
depends how alive they are
oh it's good to be back sir squiddles
cracko also welcome back nice to see you
would you be amenable to being bribed to
play some untitled goose game
i have some really good tea
uh remind me again send me a whisper for
yeah whisper me instructions to download
that
and then
i know there is demand for it at some
point i think during my
12 hour stream i was very close to
playing it
but it requires
steam
it requires some software that i don't
know how to use
i was thinking this hitting the knights
but uh there's just knight d6
so play bishop
bishop b5 looks nice
pinning getting ready to castle
[Music]
hey
okay
i see har krishnan's request
let's do something to haru krishnan
i think you've earned the vip title also
sorry for misspelling your name
there we go
[Music]
i need to remove a vip before i can add
more
or maybe i can just send an angry email
to twitch
ask for more vip slots
wow look at this move
bishop takes d7
if king takes i play this
queen takes i take with check
bishop takes i win the knight
oh to elaborate
if king g7 queen c6 king hear
uh knight e4 bishop e4 and then queen c5
so every which line i win a piece
black's best try might be to sack both
rooks
like queen takes
i take this rook i take the other rook
then there's bishop f2
[Music]
but i don't think it leads to much
here we go
yeah black wants to play queen e7 but
then i
do some damage
no mercy here
i'm of two knights
and two pawns
go one of my
nights i mean i could plot your vip slot
new challenge each piece type must move
once before the same type can move again
oh that actually sounds kind of cool
wait let me try and internalize what
that means
okay this is a desperado move
i was gonna lose a night anyway and i'd
rather
uh preserve casting rights
so after takes on all castle
oh but then rook f no rook f3 i take the
the rook on eight
wait so super misplays says
wait virus threat
okay
i think i have enough defensive
resources
to defend against virus threats
might depend on the virus though
wait let me see if i can unvip someone
[Music]
okay here's what i'll do
i'm going to unvip chess
to vip hari krishnan
welcome back sir
hey good to be back
icelandic noob
icelandic noob i'm doing a sub battle
in
11 hours
if you're interested
islamic noob is like a hero from one of
the previous sub-battles
why not take the bishop
uh
i got a little bit distracted i didn't
see the bishop was free
and now because i saw that comment in
chat
i'm not going to take the bishop
i'm going to fork the queen and the
bishop
also oh no my bishop
good to be back
venom klaus
and if queen takes my bishop i'm not
gonna take the bishop
wait does that force mate
oh it's so beautiful if queen takes
bishop it's made in like
five
i mean five right
or four or five
hey okay
so knight f7 originally i thought i was
just gonna win the queen
this is
a this is a disco fork
a discovered fork
um
but on top of this
all of vox things are in danger the
bishop's still hanging this rook is
potentially hanging if takes black is
getting back right mated
after queen d a queen d bishop ea queen
eight or cafe queen of fate
if king here
then
my queen and my knight are hanging
but black can't take anything because
it's double check
and now oh no my queen
dot com
and then checkmates
wait i wonder if it's working now
oh no my queen dot com
hey okay it's working so oh no my queen
dot com redirects to my merch site now
which is kind of nice
i bought the domain name like a year ago
and then i forgot about it
and then i set up the redirect earlier
today
okay
i hope reddit chess is satisfied now
this is a nice little
this is a smothered fork
smothered fork disco fork
the previous game was a pork mate
man so much beauty
but not so vegetarian
oh a smork
oh i like that word
it sounds like s'more
maybe when you eat a s'more with a fork
by the time this goes on youtube
i'll have a coupon code for my merch
site
you can get some oh no my queen merch
and
use code smork
for
what's a good number
for 13 percent off all orders